[موسيقى]
قتلوا الزلم
لم تختبري النزوح طوال السنوات الحرب
سوريا الا ان رعب الزلزال دفعها لهجر
منزلها المدمر لتلجا الى من يشاركها
الماساه باختلاف الدافع منى والعديد ممن
نجوا من الزلزال المدمر الذي ضربت تركيا
وسوريا
ستجدوا بنازح الحرب في ادلب ليحتموا في
خيامهم
ناجحين وعرفوا
الله هيك بعدهم وحنان علينا واعطونا اغراض
من عندهم
زلزال القرن فاجا السكان في وقت باكرا من
الصباح ليهربوا من منازلهم بملابس النوم
حفاه مشهد مرعب عشه هذا الاب مع اطفاله
الاربعه حصل يعني صعبك جدا جدا يعني
كانه يوم القيامه يعني شغله كبيره كتير
وقت البنايه
وهز قويه كتير كتير طلعنا حفيانين
بالرومات وبالمي والمطر يعني وضع صعب جدا
جدا
نازحوا الحرب الهاربون من القصف ومدافع
النظام السوري احتضنوا النازحين الجدد فقد
اشتركوا في خراب المنازل والرعب من الموت
بقى احنا سوينا اللي علينا جمعنا بعض
هالنساء بعضها الاطفال جبناها لعنا على
الخيام طلعنا برات خيامنا وحطيناهم
وسوينا اللي علينا يعني لفيناهم دفيناهم
ما بين طلع الضوء
تعددت الاسباب والموت واحد لتكون الخيام
جامعه المصائب السوريه ان كانت بفعل
الطبيعه او الانسان واحتمال النجاه الضعيف
اذا عمر العربيه